I need you to stay quiet this is a me
thing it is
we see got that fine but make it quick
one of I think our great hopes for
future films is other articulations of
denim as fans the comics will no
Carnage's the bond between Cletus Kasady
a serial killer and the red symbiote and
so this movie will introduce Cletus
Kasady hi Eddie carnage is the promise
of the venom character taken to the next
level so you know going into venom you
were hoping that there'd be carnage and
they delivered in a very delightful way
that made you go alright I'll give you
more of my money if you do this again
welcome back everybody it's Charlie we
got a whole bunch of new venom to
carnage in spider-man stuff to talk
about so we'll break it down I know
there are a lot of rumors about what's
going on with spider-man now in the Sony
spider-verse in the venom movies I will
address that during the video we're
doing a spider-man far from home blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about venom 2 on the video the
cool thing about that carnage venom 2
teasers them talking about future
iterations of the Venom symbiote we'd
like to do more versions of the
character they're also talking about
going beyond carnage that means if you
really want them to do toxin they're
probably planning on doing him at some
point
venom 2 is getting ready to shoot in
London during November there's a very
important reason why they're shooting it
in November because the movie is not
going to take place in San Francisco
like the first movie did woody harrelson
is coming back as carnage Michelle
Williams is coming back for an weighing
in more she venom they said that they
really liked the way that went down in
the first film in Michelle Williams
really liked playing that version of the
character so they're gonna double down
on that a little bit Andy Serkis is
gonna be the director probably the most
famous motion capture artist in the
world right now makes sense he's a solid
pic for working with Tom Hardy the venom
and carnage characters any other future
symbiotes that you want to do the
working title of the movie is Fillmore
Tejas a reference to the film or music
venue in San Francisco the first movie
took place in San Francisco that's the
only real significance of that working
title no huge easter eggs the Tom
Hollands spider-man movies used Seinfeld
references as their working titles the
working title for spider-man homecoming
was summer of George which is the title
of a Seinfeld episode and the one that
they used for spider-man far from home
was fall of George the reason why they
picked summer of George for spider-man
homecoming was because they kept talking
about that episode during pre-production
they were obsessed with Seinfeld they
thought it was really funny to use that
as the working title of the movie then
when it came time to shoot spider-man
far from home they just continued the
joke but a lot of you may have realized
the really important reason why the
venom 2 movie is shooting in London is
mostly because they're doing more Sony
spider-verse world-building with the
venom versus carnage fight but also
crossing it over with Jared Leto's
Morbius spin-off movie because that
movie shot in London near Manchester to
make it look like
New York City the actual plot of the
Morbius movie takes place in New York
City which means that venom two might
also be taking place in New York City
suddenly everyone's spidey sense is
going off like crazy I'll address the
spider-man of it all in a second the
Morbius movie isn't coming out till July
next year after Comic Con but odds are
pretty good we'll see some sort of venom
reference at the end of that movie
setting up the reason why venom has to
go to New York City from San Francisco
because it's all about him
fighting carnage carnage doesn't have
the symbiote yet he's stuck in San
Quentin prison near San Francisco so
venom going to New York City in the
sequel probably has something to do with
either a carnage escaping prison after
he gets the symbiote or him being
transferred to a New York City prison
like Rikers because in the comics the
carnage origin story happens when Eddie
Brock and Cletus Kasady are cellmates in
a New York City prison it's not clear
how faithful they'll be to the comic
book carnage origin story in the movie
but there has to be a reason for the
Venom symbiote to spawn and offspring in
proximity to Cletus Kasady
otherwise the only other way to explain
how he gets the symbiote is that
someone's experimenting on the Venom
symbiote and somehow it spawns and then
he gets it you can make all kinds of
theories about the Morbius movie and him
having something to do with carnage
eventually getting the symbiote but it
feels too soon to completely cross all
those characters over yet so I'm still
expecting venom 2 to just be venom
carnage with a little bit of Morbius and
a little bit of spider-man that I'll
talk about in a second because let's
just address the New York City
spider-man shaped elephant in the room
if the movie does take place in New York
City and they confirmed that they're
crossing over Tom Hollands spider-man
with the venom franchise
how long can venom carnage and Morbius
now who's also in New York City fight
before spider-man takes notice and tries
to do something about it post all your
spongebob memes in the comments there
was a rumor that because of the Marvel
Sony split now Sony was gonna lean into
all this venom crossover business and
they'd find some way to tease spider-man
crossover during venom 2 but he wouldn't
be a big part of the plot maybe just a
reference to spider-man during the
post-credits scene so that they can do
maximum carnage for venom 3 because that
feels like the direction they're taking
this franchise then they can still do
spider-man 3 in 22
twenty-one setting-up sinister six
separately from all the venom stuff but
also teasing some venom crossover at the
end of spider-man three but the timeline
of venom to the Morbius movie in
spider-man 3 is not totally clear
because it sounds like all those movies
take place in New York City and even
though is a really big city you have to
have a timeline that makes sense for why
they're not all together on screen right
away the Morbius movie next year is
probably gonna do most of that work and
even if Sony and Marvel aren't sharing
the character and Sony can no longer use
Iron Man or the Avengers characters they
can still use the timeline created by
Avengers endgame it can still be 2023
and present-day but the easiest way that
they can just avoid any complications
with that is just by not referencing
what year it is at all during the movie
just to avoid confusion just say that
the actual crossover movie spider-man 4
or venom 3 is just set in present-day
the thing about spider-man and venom
versus carnage in a maximum carnage
movie though that people have not been
talking about is Morbius and the other
spider verge spin-off movies that Sony
is trying to do there's a silk movie
there's still a craven movie that
they're clearly trying to set up during
this Morbius movie look at these trucks
there's Kraven written all over the side
of them it sounds kind of like they want
him to be a Morbius villain at some
point why would you put this on the side
of a truck so prominently in broad
daylight if you didn't intend on using
the character in a big way we're still
kind of in the middle of convention
season right now Tom Holland just did a
convention appearance where he talked
about the Marvel Sony split he said that
they'd already pitched the story of
spider-man 3 to Sony that they had new
crazy crossovers in the Sony
spider-verse planned this is the clip of
him talking about that
[Applause]
i sat down with some of our communities
and you pitch one month three which is
going to be something very special the
mob will change my life so when all
these appearances all these interviews
he's been doing he's been trying to hype
up the idea that they have new
quote-unquote interesting crossover
ideas very clearly trying to tell us
that yes we're going to be doing a lot
of venom crossover in the future
there was another rumor recently a lot
of you asked me to address in the video
about Spider Man coming back into the
MCU as part of a new deal that required
that they let venom into the MCU that
was part of Sony's terms right now I
don't believe that rumor I'm trying to
take most of what they're saying with a
grain of salt but the Sony CEO did say
that for the time being there was no
deal to be had they're gonna continue
making spider-man 3 on their own if
Marvel and Sony come back to the table
it's probably not gonna be till around
the time they get ready to release
spider-man 3 so don't worry because it
wasn't gonna be a lot of spider-man in
Marvel phase 4 movies outside of
spider-man 3 anyway so it's not like
you're suddenly missing a whole lot of
spider-man that you otherwise would have
gotten we're still gonna get spider-man
3 in 2021 there's still potential for
them to work out a sharing arrangement
in him to come back during Avengers 5
but that's not gonna happen during
Marvel phase 4 anyway so they still have
plenty of time to figure that out and in
the meantime he can do all these venom
crossovers he can get the symbiote so
you can finally get black costume true
black costume Tom Hollands spider-man
and then he can come back to the MCU and
tell everybody about the crazy adventure
he had with the symbiote from outer
space on the venom side of all this
crossover stuff the last time Tom Hardy
talked about crossing over with Tom
Hollands character was during Comic Con
last year and because that was before
the big Sony Marvel split he was still
talking about it as if it would have
been him coming into the MCU this is the
clip of him talking about that
université domain and that's that was
already a complete standalone piece and
when I read it I'm quite mercenary and
quite selfish in that aspect very very
happy to have a standalone character
within the Marvel context in one world
but all to myself so I'm kind of greedy
and aspect but at the end of day that's
that's kind of above my paygrade and
also it's not my daddy's tractor so I
don't know where it fits it in the grand
scheme of things so I would never ruin
anything out the bloody thing about that
is that he's trying to be as political
as possible clearly he's a little bit
better at this than Tom Holland like he
isn't giving away big spoilers or
anything like that but what he's saying
is is that when they pitched him the
venom movie they said that it'd be a
solo movie they probably teased the idea
that he might crossover with Tom
Hollands spider-man character but it's a
franchise meant to be built around him
not around spider-man so a lot of times
the actors aren't really clued into the
really big things that are going on in
the background with these crossovers
they just take it one movie at a time
that being said he does say that he's a
huge fan of the idea so of course he
wants to crossover with spider-man at
some point but everybody post your venom
two theories in the comments below
do you actually think there's gonna be a
spider-man post-credit scene and how do
you think they're gonna try and connect
the Morbius movie to the venom sequel as
long as the movies are good I totally
cool with whatever they want to try as
long as they eventually let spider-man
come back into an MCU film for Avengers
5 that's all I care about they can do
whatever they want to in the meantime
there's a bunch of new Marvel stuff I'm
working on this weekend as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all the videos when I post
them congratulations Dave Suggs you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everybody click here for my brand-new
Avengers Fantastic Four teaser video and
click here for all my spider-man Easter
egg videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight